- [Narrator] This factory in Germany
has made engines for some
of the most popular cars
in the world for over five decades.
- [Announcer] Ever wish
you owned a Volkswagen?
- [Narrator] But more
recently, some of those cars
have lost their shine.
- [Reporter] VW owners coming to grips
with the realization
that their diesel cars
can emit from 10 to 40
times more pollutants.
- We all know that we
have let down customers.
- [Narrator] What's more, global sales
of internal combustion
engines are predicted to drop
by over 50% by 2035.
The hot new market? Electric vehicles.
So to try and capture that market,
VW is transforming this engine factory
into it's new EV battery facility,
the first of six that it
plans to build in Europe
at a cost of about 15 billion dollars,
according to analysts.
- What you see behind us has nothing to do
with combustion engines
and that shows the size
of this transformation.
- [Narrator] That means going
from making combustion engines
that have more than 2,000 moving parts,
to high-tech electric motors
that only have about 20,
and changing it's workforce to do that.
- Traditional automakers, if
they wanna be in this market
in 2035, they need to develop
just as much as the startup's
need to develop.
- [Narrator] The EV market is
currently dominated by Tesla
and faces disruption from
a bunch of new startups.
- They have nothing to lose,
they start from scratch.
We have a lot to lose.
- [Narrator] So could this
factory be a blueprint
for traditional automakers
to survive the EV revolution?
While VW says that its
battery factory in Salzgitter
won't be online for
another two years or so,
Tesla already has several
gigafactories in operation,
and completed its Shanghai
facility in under a year.
It also says it's nearing
completion of a huge plant
here in Germany.
- We've decided to put
Tesla gigafactory Europe
in the Berlin area.
- [Narrator] Other well funded startups
like Lucid and Rivian have
set up brand new factories
to start EV production this year.
So legacy automakers like GM, Ford and VW
have all announced
they're investing billions
into EV production to
defend their market share,
with VW committing to 43
billion dollars in five years.
- When you look at what
the startups are doing,
they don't have to transition.
You don't have to change
a legacy footprint,
so traditional automakers
don't have the luxury
of sitting back and saying, ah,
we'll wait and see how it goes.
- We are responsible for the
people and for our customers
and we have to transform.
- [Narrator] So how is VW investing
that money in Salzgitter?
Well, some of those decisions are made
by this engineer, Frank Blome.
- We are building a small
scale sales right now
and we are building up the
first mass production plant.
- [Narrator] VW has converted
part of its existing facotry
into labs and a pilot line to
test and refine the science
behind its batteries.
It plans to build a brand new
facility right next to it,
which could produce batteries
for over 600,000 vehicles
a year and is expected to cost
around 2.5 billion dollars,
according to analysts.
Although it says it hasn't
finalized the designs
for it's new facility yet,
the factory is expected to be
similar to this one in Sweden.
It's owned by battery supplier Northvolt
and VW is a major investor in the company.
Thomas Schmall is CEO of
VW's component division.
- The bottle neck will be
how fast you can establish,
increase and ramp up
your battery business.
- [Narrator] Within it's labs,
VW is trying to figure out
what kind of battery's it's
electric vehicles will need
in the future.
It's testing battery recycling technology
and to get ahead of the competition,
it's experimenting with next generation,
solid state batteries which
don't contain liquid lithium,
and promise far fasting
charging and greater mileage.
- Fast charge is a big, big topic for us.
We are working on that
with a big workforce.
- [Narrator] The transition
will effect everyone
in this plant.
The company will need
fewer mechanical engineers
and will need new people with
totally different skills,
like electro-chemists or developers,
as EV's need so much software
that VW is set to become
one of the largest tech
companies in Europe.
- To find the right people is a challenge.
It's a new industry,
everybody wants electro-chemistry people.
- I think the big outstanding question is,
we know that it will take fewer employees
to build a battery cell pack,
so therefore, how do you figure that out?
Where do you transition people to?
- [Narrator] As the battery plant grows,
over time, part of the
staff will be retrained,
while some legacy jobs
are expected to go away.
At the end of this transition,
it's unclear whether the
overall number of workers
on this site will go down.
Globally, VW has already made some cuts.
In 2019, the company
announced that it was cutting
some 7,000 jobs over five years
and since 2016, it has eliminated
at least 23,000 positions
by offering early retirement
and not replacing workers.
- We always have this issue, oh,
maybe it's destroying
business, not supplied.
You can, if you do it
right, you can create jobs.
We will have 1,500, 1,600 employees
in the new sale business,
what we are doing here,
and that's not the end,
because this is only the first portion
of the first part of the cell plant.
- [Narrator] The stakes are
particularly high for VW
as it's trying to change
it's image as a polluter,
while also meeting new
environmental regulations
around the world.
After the emission scandal in 2015,
VW pleaded guilty to installing
a device on it's vehicles
to cheat US emissions tests.
- It is not only our cars we have to fix,
we know we have to repair
our credibility too.
- [Narrator] Today, as
VW bets big on electric,
it's US sales are much lower
than they were in 2012.
- I think it does dovetail
with needing to prove
that they're clean and having
that hanging over their heads
'cause it does, news doesn't stop on that.
It does still pop up, so the
issue isn't completely dead.
- [Narrator] So just like this factory,
the decades old company
has to reinvent itself
to keep up with technology and
beat competitors old and new.
(gentle music)